when i was a kid i used to wonder how it
was possible that the roman republic
could just fall
the roman republic and the roman empire
stood for hundreds of years
and yet it all came crashing down my
history teacher would say
their barbarians invaded but in truth
it collapsed from the inside out
because when caesar crossed the rubicon
it was clear
the rule of law didn't matter anymore
and that was the beginning of the end
because the rule of law matters
the mission of legal eagle is to explain
our laws to explain how the system works
when it works it's not my place to tell
you what policies our politicians should
adopt but
as a lawyer with an inside view to our
judicial system i think i have an
insight into at least this aspect of our
government
and over the last four years one thing
has become clear
president trump doesn't care about the
law he's ignorant
of the law and actively subverts the law
he uses the law for his own gain
and he breaks the law when it stands in
his way if you care about the rule of
law in america
you cannot in good conscience vote for
donald trump
this video is not about politics per se
it's not about liking or disliking the
legislation that president trump has
signed it's not about liking or
disliking the way he has handled the
govit 19 epidemic
nor is it about liking or disliking the
judges that he has appointed
this video is about the rule of law it's
about legal equity and legal equality
and it's about
justice and i guess when the scientific
american breaks with 175 years of
tradition to endorse a presidential
candidate
i guess no one including the lawyers can
stand idly by
on the sideline so for the first and
hopefully only time
legal eagle endorses a presidential
candidate legal eagle endorses joe biden
for president
he is the only candidate that has any
hope of upholding the rule of law in
this country
why because president donald trump is a
criminal
we know this to an almost certainty
there's so much evidence hiding in plain
sight
that is actually sometimes hard to
remember everything that he's done
but before we vote in november let's at
least
try you might recall that president
trump is actually unindicted
co-conspirator individual number one
to the conspiracy michael cohen has
already pleaded guilty to regarding the
illegal hush money payments to porn
stars
michael cohen the president's former
attorney pleaded guilty to eight
criminal charges
five counts of tax evasion one count of
making false statements to a financial
institution
one count of willfully causing an
unlawful corporate contribution
and one count of making an excessive
campaign contribution at the request
of president trump for the principal
purpose of influencing the election
michael cohen went to jail for those
crimes and committed those crimes at the
direction of the president
but now president trump did not go to
jail
he stayed in office but that doesn't
make him any less guilty than the people
that he directed
and after president trump stayed in
office he tried to use
400 million dollars in taxpayer funds
allocated for the defense of
ukraine to fabricate dirt on his
political opponent
effectively the president tried to
blackmail a strategic partner using
taxpayer funds
into soliciting a bribe for his own
benefit and
not for nothing to try and create
exactly the kind of narrative that he
was able to use in 2016 against his
former opponent
it was beautiful it was just a perfect
conversation
after the scheme was discovered the
president then punished the
whistleblowers who brought it to the
public's attention
apart from the illegality this is the
kind of malfeasance that goes straight
to the heart of our democracy
this is about interfering with the
voter's choice this is about creating
black propaganda for one's own benefit
and this is about using the funds the
mighty forces of the united states
for one's own personal benefit and you
might recall that
the watergate break-in occurred because
president nixon wanted an election
advantage do not forget that president
trump was
impeached however he was not removed
but that doesn't mean that his actions
were neither impeachable nor
illegal it means that certain political
figures made a political decision to
allow him to stay and if our political
leaders don't have the stones to do
anything about it and would rather we
just forgot the whole affair
it's our job to remember when we vote
and we've been lucky that
much of the president's illegality has
been bone-headed and incompetent but we
might not be so lucky next time
and that's how we bungled our way into
the er scandal of the trump
administration when the president
started to politicize the entire
enforcement wing of the executive branch
when the president fired the director of
the fbi specifically because he was
investigating the president's ties to
russia
then the president told the russians in
a secret oval office meeting i faced
great pressure because of russia
that's taken off and then the president
admitted to the entire thing to lester
holt on national television
when i decided to just do it i said to
myself i said you know
this russia thing with trump and russia
is a made-up story it's an excuse
by the democrats for having lost an
election that they should have won
and then as we know from the mueller
report there was an entire scheme to
cover all of this up
the muller report is practically a
flashing red siren that says that the
president and his accomplices
engaged in an obstruction of justice on
par or worse than the watergate scandal
and yet for prudential reasons they
decided not to refer it for prosecution
hoping that the legislative branch would
do something about it
and of course unfortunately they did not
but that doesn't change the impropriety
of the underlying
conduct and the second half of the
muller report is almost equally damning
that
even if the trump administration and the
trump organization did not engage in
actual conspiracy and collusion with the
russians they still solicited and
encouraged illegal hacking for their own
personal gain
and certainly benefited from that
hacking and then of course there's a
whole raft of
pettier but equally damning malfeasance
for example the president's solicitation
of
emoluments now granted there are open
questions about the limits of the
emoluments clause in the constitution
but it's clear that the president has
more conflicts of interest than
any president in history the president
owns and operates
myriad businesses while holding office
which is rife for conflicts of interest
hundreds of thousands of dollars have
been spent by the u.s military
under extraordinarily suspicious
circumstances at the trump turnberry
gulf resort
and failing to divest himself has left
himself open to bribes from every
visiting politician in dc
who loved to brag about staying in the
trump dc hotel
and from every foreign business partner
including china where the president
holds an undisclosed bank account
potentially to hide foreign corrupt
practices can you imagine if i
had a secret chinese bank account when i
was running for re-election
you think fox news might have been a
little concerned about that
the president has asked his attorney
general to interfere with the
prosecution of trump loyalists
the president has gassed protesters
exercising their first amendment rights
to get a photo op
in lafayette square the president has
sent federal troops into cities on
a whim he's turned the government into
his own personal campaign and fails to
punish government employees who violate
the hatch act
and again this goes to the heart of the
democracy incumbents get a huge
advantage by operating the levers
of the government and he seems to
operate the entire us government as his
own personal re-election campaign
which is probably good because the last
three campaign heads that he's had are
actual convicted felons or in the case
of brad parskel are about to be felons
the president has almost surely engaged
in manifest tax evasion
he likes to pardon and commute the
sentences of his cronies who have
engaged in
real illegality obstruction of justice
and lying to the government
and as part of that he has politicized
the department of justice leading to
investigations for his own political
gain and retribution
he interferes with the prosecution of
his friends and business partners
and unfortunately this is the tip of the
iceberg because the president has fired
most of the inspectors general often
after they have found improprieties
within the trump administration
unless we forget one of the most
disgusting things he said
he admitted to forcible sexual assault
before he was elected the first time
and when you're a star they let you do
it you can do anything whatever you want
grab them i can do anything
the president doesn't deserve the
benefit of the doubt he had his chance
and at least in this respect he was
worse than a lot of us could have
imagined
this is apart from issues of politics or
competence i wouldn't fault you at all
if you chose not to vote for trump
because of his politics but
it's not my role as a lawyer and legal
commentator to tell you about your
political beliefs
and similarly i might agree with you if
you felt he didn't deserve the vote
because he was wildly incompetent like
either ignores his daily classified
briefings or requires them to be in
picture book format incompetent or
injecting disinfectant into your veins
incompetent injection
inside or or almost a cleaning again i
say maybe you can maybe you can't i'm
not a doctor
but i'm like a person that has a good
you know what
or like staring into a solar eclipse
incompetent
but what i am saying is that some things
are apolitical
or that even if you agree 100 with what
the precedent stands for from a
political perspective
perhaps there are more important things
like the rule of law
the problem is that once you lose it you
never get it back
and there is a barbarian in the white
house
president trump is not the candidate of
law and order
he cares about a certain kind of order
all right but
not the law a vote for president trump
is a vote that says the law
doesn't matter it's a vote that says
it's okay if the rich and powerful use
the law unequally
it's a vote that says criminals will not
be punished
but that only happens if we allow it
i still believe the law matters
i still believe in equal protection
i still believe in justice
and i hope you do too
and i hope that you consider the rule of
law when you vote
you